[Applause]
[Music]
i'm going to start today with a question
you probably already know the answer to
which country is the world's largest
movie producer i know that you know that
it's not the united states but instead
it's
india
[Music]
we've all heard about bollywood movies
now the question is why are indian
movies so popular why does the us have
such a hard time selling movies in india
sure every country has their own local
movie industry but when it comes to the
box office hollywood blockbusters
dominate the highest grossing films
india is an exception to this
only 13 of the revenue made from the
film industry in india comes from
american movies
if you thought the answer is the huge
indian population you better think again
large though it is
india has more than 26 regional
languages in fact when indians talk
about bollywood they're referring to the
hindi language film industry which
produces only about 20
of the total number of movies produced
by the indian film industry the other 80
are made in the other regional languages
bengali marathi tamil and so on each
language has its own industry with its
own stars and studios despite these
issues in 2019 alone india produced more
than 2
200 movies
the indian movie industry is so big and
influential it's even a political tool
this is what the former indian prime
minister manmohan singh
once said about indian movies
whenever i go in the middle east in
africa people talk about
indian films so that is a new way of
influencing the world about the growing
importance of india
soft power is equally important in the
new world of diplomacy
former prime minister of india indian
movies are so influential that one
single movie made indian tourism to
spain grow nine point five percent in
one year the movie was called
zendagi namaligi dobara life doesn't
come again it was about three indian
guys taking a road trip to spain in fact
you know what is the world's biggest
youtube channel it's not pewdiepie or in
fact visual politics it's
t-series a channel that broadcasts
bollywood visual clubs
and make no mistake indian movies are
getting more and more popular worldwide
china despite the bad political
relationship with india is a huge
consumer of bollywood movies but we'll
talk about that a little later on and by
the way
unlike hollywood studios which are
mainly located in a town called
hollywood on the outskirts of los
angeles there is no actual place
called bollywood nevertheless you could
say that most of the hindi language
movies are produced in one city mumbai
or as it used to be called bombay just
like los angeles and the us
mumbai is a thriving and cosmopolitan
city with good weather
all year round the perfect place for
making movies but now the
question is how did indian movies become
so popular how did politics affect this
industry and why do the chinese prefer
watching indian films over the latest
star wars movie although to be fair
the latest star wars movies weren't
great today we're going to answer all
these questions but first let's take a
look at some history
it all began with jesus christ yes
that's right the year was 1911 and an
indian man
named dadasheb falaki i'm so sorry india
he took his family to watch a movie the
life of christ now remember that india
was a british colony at the time so the
movies were mainly for the entertainment
of the british colonisers nevertheless
fellaini was so mesmerized by the movie
he imagined that similar movies could be
produced with personalities from indian
history and epics
so falaki traveled to london learned
filmmaking came back to india secured
funding
and produced raja harichatrandra it was
india's first home run feature film
[Music]
it was a 40-minute silent film about a
king from hindu mythology and was
screened for the public at coronation
cinema in mumbai in 1913.
over the next decade or so several
silent films were produced in india
initially they were based on indian
mythology but soon the plots made way
for adaptations of novels and then
in 1931 india's first movie with audio
or talkie was produced it was ardesher
irani's
[Music]
the concept was so fascinating for the
people that it's reported that police
had to control the crowds that went
berserk
at mumbai's cinema theater even before
independence india made its debut in kan
in 1946 when the film nietzsche nagar
won the pandora or the best film award
it paved the way for social realism in
indian cinema and what followed was the
golden age period of indian cinema
following independence when movies
addressed societal issues and
working-class conditions sentiments of
the anti-colonial struggle of the
previous decade
reflected through cinema later in the
70s and 80s filmmakers explored the
genre of action films and urban noir and
from then
we jumped to the 90s when films revolved
around traditional family values
[Music]
the film industry was flourishing but
there was one problem the indian movie
industry was not recognized as an
industry by the government
remember this is india a heavily
state-centric economy not being
recognized by the government means
producers couldn't get finance from any
banks or financial institutions
of course it wasn't illegal but it was
marginalized by the political and
economic system so
what happens when a whole industry is
forced to operate outside of the banks
and the institutions we're going to take
a look at that now
[Music]
when bollywood went underworld by the
1990s organized crime had a prominent
presence in mumbai but their sources of
income except narcotics were dwindling
meanwhile
bollywood was growing to be a lucrative
business and the underworld wanted a
slice of the film industry's pie besides
the producers needed to make films with
higher budgets so they could remain
competitive against foreign movies so
yes
many movies in the 1990s were funded by
gangsters and as you can imagine
dealing with gangsters is not great
business got an example
of course you do so here's one
[Music]
the dubai-based gangster abu saleh was
threatening filmmaker
subhash gai for the foreign distribution
rights of his hit film
pardes eventually the police failed an
attack by salem's hit squad to
understand the gravity of the situation
let me say that salem is now serving a
life sentence in
india in connection with the 1993 bomb
blasts in mumbai that left
257 people dead
[Music]
filmmakers such as rakesh roshan mahesh
batt and boni kapoor
so sorry india all reported that they
received calls from the mafia demanding
profit sharing meanwhile the mafia would
threaten successful actors to sign on to
star in films where they had vested
financial interests other times mafia
dons would intimidate filmmakers to cast
their lovers for example in 1995 a movie
director called javed sadiq was shot
dead because he didn't want to cast a
gangster's lover in a movie the
relationship between organized crime and
movies was so pervasive it even appeared
on wikileaks
elite us diplomatic cable has said that
bollywood welcomed funding from
gangsters and politicians
known in india as black money economic
times but
the real turning point came with do you
remember t-series the world's biggest
youtube channel so that channel belongs
to t-series one of the biggest music and
film producers in
india its founder was gulshan kumar in
1997 he was shot dead by one of india's
most notorious drug dealers dawud
ibrahim this man by the way is the
suspected mastermind of the 1993 mumbai
bombing with this killing
many other cases came to light which
once had been an open secret quickly
became a number one priority for the
police after so many decades the
government decided to change their views
on movies
bollywood hazy about new industry status
but expects business to get streamlined
now india today
1998. in 1998 the film industry finally
got the status of a formal industry
under the purview of the central and
state governments a slew of changes
follows in the year 2000 the industrial
development bank act opened the doors
for the film industry to access
legitimate financing and the union
budget doled out tax incentives large
banks as well as corporations were keen
to invest in this sector india's telecom
giant reliance and the tv content
producer utv
all expanded their business to include
film production as film financing became
less risky the industry reliance on
underworld money abated though the
threats of extortion did not stop
entirely as recently as 2015 about 10
members of mafia dawn ravi pujari's gang
were arrested and later convicted of
allegedly comprising to kill
filmmaker mahesh bat but enough of the
drama so far we know that movies became
an industry in their own right in india
but we still haven't answered the key
question
in this video let's move on to that
right now
why are indian movies so popular as we
said at the beginning bollywood refers
to the hindi language films in india but
there are many other bollywoods and
sometimes they can even surpass the
original one for example in 2012 there
were 262 films in tamil the language
spoken in cities like chennai and just
in hindi actually the movies shot in the
telugu language have been increasing a
lot in recent years but all these
different industries have one thing in
common they all experienced a turning
point when they were recognized by the
government
in just 10 years the number of certified
movies has nearly doubled thanks to
easier financing in 2009 there were 1
279 films produced in india in 2019
there were more than 2
400 and also movies have improved
dramatically at least in terms of budget
and regional language film production
has recently expanded to encompass
languages such as nagamese
manpuri and chatter
chattesgahi i'm so sorry india while
regional language movies continue to
remain popular hindi movies are gaining
more and more market share
[Music]
in 2009 bollywood or hindi language
films accounted for about 18
of all movies made in india and just
about 19 of their revenue but a decade
later the percentage share of the number
of movies has gone up only slightly to
but these films account for 40 of their
revenue regional language films still
enjoy 47
of the revenue but here's the real
question why do hollywood and other
movie producers represent as little as
the answer as always is complex but we
are going to tell you
the first reason is censorship
international as well as indian films
have to deal with india's sensors but
unlike other countries that censor
movies the indian rules are
completely unpredictable they depend on
who's in the government at that
particular point in time for example
there was a time when sex and intimacy
were forbidden to be shown in the movie
so anytime there was an erotic scene
there was lots of flowers covering it do
you ever that scene from the titanic
where kate winslet appears naked
indians missed that sorry india but for
a different reason this time but now the
censorship rules are focused on
geopolitics this explains why in 2018
scenes mentioning maps of kashmir and
mission impossible were censored when
the movie was screened in
india
of course if you're a bollywood producer
your movies are made to meet all the
censorship lots but many american movies
are screened without some scenes that
are crucial
to understanding the plot but wait a
minute because this is not the only
reason many countries movie ticket
pricing is more or less consistent the
ticket costs the same regardless of the
movie you are watching india is a
totally different ball game tickets are
priced dynamically so you don't pay the
same
if you want to watch an important movie
as if you want to watch a locally made
one in fact ticket prices can be
different even for the same movie
depending on the choice of seats or even
the time of day
but hold on because we are not done yet
as we said before india has
lots of different languages many of
which are butchered just pronouncing
many of them understandably are not
understandable from one another so
dubbing a movie only in hindi won't work
for the whole indian market i know
you're going to be thinking now being so
successful the indian movie industry
must be a great business right well
not really
in 2019 the entire movie industry had a
revenue of 13.3 billion dollars and the
movie industry employed over 200 000
people and you might be thinking
are those big numbers well as a
comparison the movie avengers endgame
made 2.79 billion dollars on its own and
here is the craziest part of this story
you might think indians are
huge fans of going to the movies but in
fact screen penetration in this country
is way below the average there are only
about 6.5 movie screens per million
people this indeed varies across the
country
but compare it to 23 in china and 126 in
the us
plus india has massive piracy problems
which reportedly cost the industry over
260 million dollars in losses every year
and while the ticket prices have been
rising they are still
much lower than in the west of course
many of these trends are starting to
change because of the video on demand
services like
netflix but ticket sales are not the
only way that the industry makes money
if you've watched indian movies you know
that music and choreographed dance
sequences are often an integral part of
these films an important revenue source
for production houses is through selling
music rights and revenue sharing
agreements usually with one of the big
labels like t series
z music or sony music
in fact the money earned by selling
rights to the official soundtrack is
used as seed capital for film production
and one platform where music streaming
is incredibly popular is youtube and
that is why t-series is such
a huge channel yes even bigger than
visualpolitik the revenue earned by the
film industry through music is estimated
at over 200 million dollars and some 5
000 jobs in the film industry can be
attributed to the music department which
is nearly a third of all jobs in the
recorded music industry okay so this is
the business side of the industry but
now we need to get to the political
side of it because trust me this is
india there is a political side to this
story
[Music]
from bollywood to the rest of the world
so now i'm going to ask you a question
have you ever seen an
indian movie if you're watching this
from the us australia or europe chances
are
you probably haven't you might think
indian movies are made for indians only
but you'd better think again for example
russians really love their bollywood
films during the 1950s both india and
the soviet union shared a common
aversion to western colonial powers and
there began the love story between
bollywood and russia
[Music]
in 1951 dirty kellal children of earth
was the first indian film screened in
soviet theaters the film presented a
scathing view of the bengal famine of
1943 and it was produced by ipta a
left-wing theatre group there was even
an indo-soviet co-production entitled
pardes foreigner in 1954. from there
some 300 films made their way to the
soviet union until its collapse
in 1991 and now the audience for these
films is estimated to between 20
and 60 million
russia's romance with raj kapoor lives
on 29 years after his death the hindu
even today
in putin's russia the state-run
television channel damashini broadcasts
bollywood movies
indian actor raj kapoor whose film awara
vagabond was a roaring success in the
soviet union in the 60s continues to
evoke the nostalgia of an older
generation of russians but
it goes much further than russia there
is also a large indian diaspora around
the world and many indian films have
targeted this population going back to
the 1990s yash raj's film del wali
daliana led givenchy focused on an
indian family living in the uk i'm so
sorry india the movie was a phenomenal
success and the producer of this film
received an award from the british
tourism authority for promoting tourism
in britain in fact when former us
president barack obama visited india in
2015 he attempted an iconic monologue
from dglj
senorita
you know what i mean and one current
bollywood actor who has hit it big with
audiences around the world is none other
than the star of that movie shah rukh
khan but this movie is not only famous
in
india check this out
[Music]
bollywood stars head to morocco
hindustan times a whole contingent of
indian film personalities including
shahrukh khan attended the marrakesh
international film festival in morocco
where they have a swarm of fans
deeply passionate about indian cinema
there king muhammad vi
gave a national honour to shahrukh khan
and i know what many of you might be
thinking
if you are a loyal visualpolitik fan
you've seen our videos where we talk
about how the muslim minorities are
treated in india you could say that
hindus and muslims are not good friends
but again when it comes to movies it is
a completely different story
in the arab world you can find tv
channels such as z aflam that are
dedicated to broadcasting indian movies
dubbed in arabic and do you remember mr
shah ru khan check out where he is
tonight
shah rukh khan becomes brand ambassador
of dubai
connected to india but that is not all
wikileaks yes
us cables published by wikileaks has
suggested using indian actors to counter
extremism efforts in afghanistan where
indian films and actors are
hugely popular even during the taliban
times indian movies were smuggled in on
the black market but wait a minute
because we are far from done
what is the biggest emerging market
today what is the market that every
brand wants to get into
of course we're talking about china
again if you've been a visual politics
subscriber for a while you know that
china and india are not great friends
they often have skirmishes at the border
but again again when it comes to movies
it's a completely
different story check this out
don gal is nearing 150 million us
dollars at china's box office
forbes dangal an indian wrestling drama
starring amir khan opened in 9 000
screens in china this feat can of course
be attributed to the filmmakers
conscious efforts to market the film in
the neighboring country amarier went on
a promotional tour of china before the
film's release
later another film titled secret
superstar made more money in china than
star wars the last jedi
indian movies are competing head-to-head
with american movies in the world's
biggest market
so now the question is over to you will
we see indian movies dubbed into english
or spanish at some point will the indian
film industry become as influential as
the us one
and will indian people ever forgive me
enough to let me come to your beautiful
country please do leave your answers in
the comments below don't forget we
always publish brand new videos every
week so subscribe to visualpolitik and
hit the bell button so you won't miss
any posts if you like this video give us
a thumbs up and as always
i'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there